hey everyone i'm mordechai i go by mr
moore on the internet i'm here to talk
about suits and how the celebrities are
wearing them
first up we're going to show you some
blazers and shorts aka short suits when
i think of suit a suit doesn't have to
be the exact same color or even the same
fabric i think a khaki mismatched suit
or the fact that a short and jackets
work together we'll call that a suit in
2019. again i love the navy blazer
paired with gray classic white socks
with penny loafers also classic a white
polo instead of a button up
great way to do shorts uh keeping it
kind of athletic and not taking it too
seriously with a button-up shirt or
button-up shirt and tie or a bow tie
with shorts the crest on the blazer i
think also gives it an athletic feel
polo match the tennis club i really like
how pharrell is a sort of spokesperson
maybe the first to do it in that music
category or in any music category to
pull up on stage and shorts and a blazer
it takes menswear uh in a fun sporty way
on stage and i think that's what it's
about having fun and not taking yourself
too seriously i mean he's not a banker
he's not a lawyer he's not a doctor he
doesn't need to be wearing full-on
trousers and a suit jacket that fits
perfectly
western's having a mo mint i love
western i think i'm a cowboy i think all
guys might have either wanted to be
firemen or cowboys at one time when i do
put a cowboy hat on i say i want to wear
this every single day all of a sudden
post malone appears in this like
baby rose
blush pink i don't even know what we'll
call it i love all the silver studs that
kind of makes stars into a pattern and
it's not multicolored it doesn't cheapen
it i also love that instead of a
typical blazer or even a western blazer
he's wearing a sort of western jacket
it's a sort of like
milkman from the 50s james dean drizzler
gas station attendant mechanic jacket
that works so well in a western look of
course the belt being the exact same
color as the suit and boots really help
and i like how he's doing it with a
t-shirt or tank top and not a western
shirt so it's full on cowboy but it's
not costume to me because there's no hat
i love a moment on the street that's
theatrical but it might be hard for your
average dude your regular guy to go to
school to go to work in a full-on
western kit if you throw on chuck
taylors instead of the boots it might be
easier if you untuck the shirt and
you're not showing off the flashy
western belt might be a little bit
easier
but he's killing it nudie cohen was a
celebrity western costumer he did movies
as well as dressed a lot of musicians
back in the day and he became the
western tailor
[Music]
i like this category because it's sort
of
you know having fun with a tuxedo
without being too loud here i'm seeing a
young guy and he's doing it really well
you know i love the length of the tuxedo
jacket it's not shrunken i love the big
you know bow tie i love the shawl collar
with the sweeping hair you know the
cowboy hat on the knee sort of like
look at all my turquoise
he's young he's having fun other
gentlemen is wearing a bolo i believe or
some sort of string tie probably a bolo
i want to hope it's a bolo and i like
the length because it's not just like up
here when you're 90 and really heavy as
a grown man the bolo's ride up high kind
of like like he wore the same tie for 30
40 years but this is sort of
long and lean and it's it it's barely
there they might be wearing cowboy boots
they might not that's not the focus the
focus to me is it's a black tuxedo and
we're living in a time where men at most
of these award ceremonies are barely
wearing black tie in the traditional
sense so the fact that these guys are
actually wearing collared shirts the
fact that they're wearing
suits
praise them
i have a really hard time watching the
award ceremonies i feel like i'm 90 old
dodgy stodgy whatever the word is at a
men's club watching and just like ave
smh lol and all those expressions you
know i love
tradition
feminine details borrowed from the girls
gender neutral genderfluid call it what
you will it's here it's happening it's
pretty cool it's out of the box again
it's guys having fun and i support that
the babushka which i believe means
grandmother in russian
to me i'm not russian but but there are
a lot of bush goes in the neighborhood
i think that's where it comes from it's
so cool it's killer and
you know you don't have to wear anything
else loud you can wear ferragamo chanel
versace gucci any one of those loud
prints and then everything else you wear
can kind of blend right in he's going
double with the feminine hits with that
sort of long floral robe coat
and that that works well together it
looks like he might even be wearing
two or three
babushkas
but uh
it's pretty cool
i'm schvitzing just looking and thinking
of these photos you know i'm not a heavy
sweater by any means but i'm just an
average guy and with lights and makeup
and red carpets which i don't know much
about i've never walked the red carpet
maybe once i love how you know ferg did
it asap ferg he wore it long and blousy
and open and the the sleeves while they
look silky they almost look like a
comedy garcon you know who i think owns
the the mixed fabrication the best it
looks like this is actually shirting so
that's okay so the pit he's sweating is
a shirt i like two chains
shawl collar lapel that's
a very uh sort of anti-fit jacket and i
say that because he's swimming in it in
a good way it's not big by any means the
shot the collar but it doesn't look
oversized on him it's perfect but this
is sort of its own necklace i want to
peek and say hey
are you wearing something underneath
because to me that's shirtless but with
the giant medallion and all the chains
you kind of don't even notice that it's
shirtless and i like that this look with
the all-over motif the double-breasted
open is is unique to me and
you know while ferg wore her wore his
open and i really like it i like this
guy's open too if you're wearing a suit
open with no shirt you better be
confident as [ __ ] and that [ __ ] should
just be swimming it should just be like
second skin it shouldn't be like it's
wearing you you gotta wear it i don't
want to see it on the street i
definitely don't want to sit next to you
at dinner i might want to dance with you
maybe on the dance floor
i like these colors because they're not
bright they're not super pastelly easter
they're muted tones it's kind of a lilac
not a purple it's a
mustard yellow that's been washed out
mixed with a taupe jacket it's a taupe
suit with a khaki shirt so it's it's
screaming color by all means but it's
having fun without being too colorful i
like that
silk printed button-ups i love a
button-up i love silk i love a men's
blouse and i think this trend of
patterned shirts specifically floral are
having a huge moment and i love it it's
no matter of your body type big small
short tall it acts as a tie almost it
dresses up any boring suit you almost
don't even need a jacket with it because
it becomes its own its own thing i like
it when you can
see the the
all over print and it's not
abstract of a beach scene
and tennis court because if we can't see
it
what's the point i like it tucked i love
it untucked
[Music]
traditional
i love a three-piece suit
any day of the week any event pocket
watch
fob from the
vest going into the pocket watch pocket
great accents pocket square and a
boutonniere
peak lapel
i love a contrast
vest it's really nice to see white under
the blue suit he's showing a lot of tie
it's a very low vest
the tie bar not sure if it should be a
tad higher or maybe disappear i don't
know if a tie bar is necessary if it's
maybe one doo dad too much but again
it's really nice to see men in
traditional
attire i'm not exactly sure what ryan
reynolds is uh doing
i love a vest but i'm wondering where
the jacket is is it thrown to the
assistant real quick hold that i'm
sweating or
no this is the look i thought that a a
man
wears a vest as an usher in a movie
theater as a waiter busboy when you hit
the streets if you're wearing a vest or
and or a tie you probably want a jacket
with it but in this case
he looks pretty comfortable without it
when i first saw the harness i was
hoping that it had some you know secret
pockets i know they're not carrying a
gun maybe a couple joints maybe a
lighter maybe slim pocket for the phone
i like it because it's black and blends
in with the with what he's wearing it's
not white and it doesn't stand out sure
it's sort of flowery and i'm not sure
what that fabric is so it's different
than what he's wearing
but it's different you know it's not
just another jacket and it's not a vest
so call it what you want
it's a trend it's happening but
for him i actually really liked it
[Music]
i want to say wear the suit don't let
the suit wear you
but you won't know that until you take
the selfie and send it to me for
approval or your loved one because
salesmen lie
not all of them but they're going to
tell you what's an inventory they're
going to tell you what they want to sell
and maybe get commission on so you got
to go to a really trusty trusty trusty
trusty person and uh please by all means
send me pics and i'll give you my
approval thumbs up thumbs down
but
i would definitely err in the side of
oversized you know not schlumpy and
unnecessary frumpiness
but
anything but shrunken
[Music]